the hunting of Donald Trump that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now I remember when anti-trump forces
used to think that the doj should
operate independently
this is an abuse of power that the
president is again trying to manipulate
federal law enforcement to serve his
political interests this may be the most
serious Trump inappropriate doj meddling
since the firing of Comey is Trump using
his government to punish his foes and
help out his friends William Barr was
happy happy to put doj into Service as
Donald Trump's not just political Shield
but political weapon
of course Barr did nothing of the sort
that was all a lie but what a difference
a few years make in Democrats views of
right and wrong now Biden's attorney
general is doing exactly what they all
warned about under Trump he's
weaponizing the doj despite his denials
in perfect timing with the Washington
Post article that was teaming with doj
leaks about a criminal investigation
surrounding January 6 and Trump Garland
sat down with NBC to stir the pot and
drop more hints we pursue Justice
without fear or favor we intend to hold
everyone anyone who was criminally
responsible for events surrounding
January 6 for any attempt to interfere
with the lawful transfer of power from
one Administration to another
accountable that's what we do we don't
pay any attention to other issues with
respect to that I'll choreograph to
drive the new cycle and to throw some
red meat there's no way he actually
believes that what president Trump was
conspiring to overthrow the government
that is a hundred percent ludicrous it's
unsupported by testimony offered at the
January 6th Star Chamber I felt that
Richard Nixon should have been charged I
felt Bill Clinton should have been
charged uh those were easy cases those
were very clear straightforward crimes
that I think could have been it could
have resulted in rather quick
convictions that's not the current
situation with Donald Trump
now what are your views on Trump in 2024
this Garland news should really disturb
you bowing to the demands of Biden
himself and anti-trump forces in
Congress Garland's no better than the
average I don't know prosecutor working
for Vladimir Putin
political opponents are relentlessly
hunted prosecuted then jailed by a sham
Ministry of Justice there
and the New York Times does impressive
expose of Putin's vendetta-style Justice
but they take the proper justification
for Garland's investigation they take it
all at face value no concern about
potential political bias or political
motivations
I wonder why
should ask Hunter Biden a staggering
lack of curiosity about his business
conduct even when the hard drive his
hard drive was verified
but it's worse than just a media
cover-up Senator Chuck Grassley just
wrote Garland and the FBI director Chris
Ray about new whistleblower information
that describes concerns in 2020 about
the FBI's receipt and use of derogatory
information related to Hunter Biden and
the FBI's false portrayal of acquired
evidence as disinformation it's as
simple as
opening a case against Trump that was
based on fuzzy liberal newspaper reports
but when it come to hutter Biden with
plenty of concrete information it was
shut down it's pretty simple
this investigation of trump is a
complete farce any charges that stem
from this will be seen by Honest legal
observers for what they are more
political persecution not legitimate
prosecution
now remember what the New York Times
reported last April courtesy of
confidential sources that Biden wanted
Trump prosecuted he was growing tired of
how he described Garland acting as a
ponderous judge instead of a prosecutor
now those quotes were leaked for a
reason
to influence Garland well it took a
while but message received although
Garland's hedged his bets a little bit
an investigation but no prosecution yet
they seize John Eastman's cell phone and
now they're on a hunt and Peck mission
to find something anything to help
develop some type of criminal case
against the president or close
confidants that don't really exist
now this along with the January 6
committee will cost the American
taxpayers untold millions of dollars
it's going to drive countless hours of
bad programming on MSNBC and the end is
going to accomplish nothing other than
the further erosion of public confidence
in the Department of Justice and of
course of Congress
they edited evidence to take out what
might be mitigating material even
statements from from Trump that's not
how you build a case that you might
build ratings but it's not how you build
a case now hopefully the justice
department is going at this more in a
systemic professional way but we still
don't see those critical linkages
the Democrats and Liz Cheney simply
cannot let go of January 6th and the doj
they can't either they can't brag on the
economy or foreign policy so what else
are they going to do
and this new travesty that Joe manchin
by the way agreed to you know vote for
is not going to reduce inflation either
not going to be able to brag about that
that of course it's going to grow the
government
in the end the Democrats entire message
this campaign season revolves around two
things January 6 and abortion what a
depressing message
plus do you really think the Democrats
are confident they can beat Trump if
he's the nominee in 2024
although it's very early even after all
the January 6th hype Trump is winning in
a head-to-head matchup against Biden and
at least for now he's also ahead of all
other potential candidates in the 2024
primary
if I renounce my beliefs if I agreed to
stay silent if I stayed at home
and just took it easy
the persecution of Donald Trump would
stop immediately it would stop
but that's not what I will do I can't do
that I have to save our country
it's obvious to anyone who's honest with
himself that our government has been
plotting to destroy Donald Trump since
the day he announced he was running for
president
they relied on the fraudulent work
product of corrupt sleaze bags like
Christopher Steele they filed phony
papers with the fisa court to spy in his
campaign of course they hounded him with
a nearly two year long Mueller
investigation that was illegitimate from
the outset was stacked with partisans
and found no obstruction of justice in
the end and the words of Bill Barr it
was a grave Injustice
and of course the rabbit anti-trump
forces on Capitol Hill they dragged the
man through two pointless impeachments
they did nothing but distract the White
House and wasted time and resources for
what
and now the same anti-trump media frenzy
that led to so much false reporting
during his presidency oh they're
thrilled about every leak
right now it's a much more broader net
that is trying to gather everything
about team Trump and piece together what
potential crimes may have occurred
including you know the most serious one
seditious conspiracy to obstruct a
government proceeding a much more
broader net yes that's a journalist
okay a broader net every fishing
Expedition casts Nets out doesn't don't
they and garlands of course no different
now you know how pathetic this entire
investigation is when you realize that
the same party that's okay with letting
Thugs who assault police officers Go
free they think Trump should be charged
for violence committed on January 6th
the grand jury is actively investigating
Trump's criminal conduct the justice
department is interested in in two
different kinds of crime so one is the
the violence
and blood that we associate with
Insurrection day crimes like conspiracy
to defraud the United States conspiracy
to impede Congressional investigations
the conspiracy blather is not even worth
responding to its inane so why don't
these nincompoop pundits just come out
and say the truth it would be liberating
for them
Trump should be indicted because we
can't beat him otherwise
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else